Opel is offering a sporty equipment
package for its city car the atom the
atom s car tester Michelle s and maahes
going to take a closer look Michelle
describes the Opel Adam as a bubble car
solid and amicable the Opel Adam s has a
meaner look a lower ride and an almost
racy rear spoiler now she's going to see
if it lives up to its promises many
details tell the attentive observer that
the S has the makings of a sports car
the badging exhaust and the black alloy
wheels all combine to give the Adam S a
look all of its own Michelle knows the
Opel Adam as a stylish mini car and a
favorite among women but the Opel Adam s
comes across like a sporty twin brother
a product of the Oval Performance Center
Adam s is specs are also decent the
engines 110 kilowatts pushed the city
car from 0 to 100 km/h in eight point
five seconds reaching a top speed 210
[Music]
but the gearshift throw is a bit too
long for Michelle and the steering wheel
a bit too large she would have preferred
it even in tighter and sportier she has
no complaints about the handling the
special sport-tuned chassis takes the
Adam s into and around curves smoothly
the cars curb weight of under 1.2 tonnes
helps make it even more dynamic with a
high performance braking system keeping
it well under control Michelle things
Opel has designed the interior just as
impressively as the exterior in
particular she likes the roof liner the
checkered flag patent eggs the driver on
to cross the finish line and win the
race red accents inside pick up on the
same colours outside the instrument
cluster screams sports car all the way
[Music]
the Recaro seats keep a firm grip on the
driver and passenger the Adam s is width
of not quite 2 metres including the
mirrors is no different from its
siblings letting it slip easily down
narrow lanes and alleys its length is
almost the same so the S is also easy to
park at the rear the spoiler diffuser
and chrome sports exhaust maintain the
sports car styling
[Music]
all versions of the atom have the same
trunk capacity ranging from 170 to a
decent 660 liters with the rear seats
folded down
the 1.4 liter turbo gasoline burner is
reserved for the S version of the atom
and the S version of the Adam rocks
variant Michels having real fun in this
sporty city car saying it's not just the
looks it reminds her of a go-kart and
not of some outsized child's pedal
driven car but Michelle does have one
criticism
[Music]
Miffy Atia she'd appreciate a bit more
sound in the Opel Adam s somewhat brawny
a tone to go with somewhat mean attack
but at least the neighbors won't miss
that additional sound and if it's that
important to the buyers they ought to be
able to find a sports exhaust system at
an accessory shop so what is Michele's
bottom line she would have expected more
sportiness from the Opel Adam s but then
it's meant as the Adams sporty version
not an Opel Performance Center model its
interior is cozy and its handling
comfortable making it a good city car
but more fun than the regular Adam but
really starting price of nearly 12,000
euros it costs over 7,000 euros more
than the entry-level Adam that's a 60%
price hike